i'm sorry
i forgive you
okay then
hey guys pete here today i wanted to
talk about what's going on with miss
casey and severance the 107 hour old
part-time innie who we first meet as the
wellness counselor on the severed floor
at lumen then later we get the
inexplicable twist that she looks like
mark's wife who he believes is dead i'm
gonna go over everything we know about
the character and speculate as to what
might be going on here right after this
quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched all nine episodes of the first
season of severance then this video
might not be for you and with that out
of the way let's get into it we first
meet ms casey after irv falls asleep on
the job he's sent for a wellness session
and what i like about this first
interaction is that because everything
is somewhat bizarre on the severed floor
ms casey's quirks don't seem that out of
the ordinary the session consists of her
reading facts about the severed
employee's audi who they are at home you
do notice that the way she delivers
these and the way she encourages him not
to react is strange but it feels like
it's par for the course and because of
her position you aren't expecting her to
be a severed employee at this point the
next time we see her do a session is
with mark she gives him a ball of clay
to sculpt his feelings and when he
sculpts the tree from his wife's
accident you come away a lot more
concerned about what's going on with him
questions like how does any know about
that come up and what is going on with
cobell she stole the candle that gemma
made from his basement and made it part
of this session that she wanted him to
do and that she's now watching closely
miss casey's behavior becomes intriguing
when she comes to mdr to observe helly
after her suicide attempt out of her
element she seems much more awkward and
just generally more inexperienced you
saw her as a professional before and now
she seems more like a child and there's
a noticeable difference compared to what
you saw when helizani woke up for the
first time they're all sort of like
children they don't have experiences but
there seems to be something different
about miss casey later after she finds
out she's being retired you learn that
that time in mdr was her greatest memory
this was the longest period of time she
was ever awake for and the most people
she'd ever been around at the same time
she likes mark based on that and their
other interactions she thinks he's nice
because he's trying to help her but
overall they don't appear to recognize
each other the big reveal at the end of
episode 7 was mark taping the picture of
his wife back together showing us that
they look exactly the same later you get
confirmation that milcheck and cobell
know about that they know that these two
people were married and milcheck remarks
that it's a good thing they don't
recognize each other because it shows
the chip's work and we don't really get
to learn much more in season one because
cobell has her sent back to the testing
floor which is all kind of mark's fault
because he tricked her into leaving the
room so that he could get heli away from
her when a normal severed employee
retires it's like a death for that any
if you never go back to work on the
severed floor to activate those memories
they effectively cease to exist as far
as we can tell miss casey doesn't have
an audi in the real world this really
wouldn't work everyone thinks mark's
wife gemma is dead so it would cause
problems if she was walking around town
we don't know much about the testing
floor beyond the fact that she takes an
elevator that goes down from the severed
floor it seems pretty top secret and it
seems she never leaves there so it's
possible this is what petey was talking
about when he said that he found some
employees that never left as far as
gemma's concerned we've gotten some
details but mostly she served to be this
absence that mark feels in his life she
was a russian literature professor
everyone around mark seemed to like her
she was allergic to nutmeg she liked
other people's pets and she thought
cardigans looked ridiculous from what we
can tell they were in love and they had
a good relationship one issue they
seemed to have was that they thought
about having kids but weren't able to
her death was unexpected and it left
mark's life in shambles the people
around him all understand how the loss
affected him they know he's in bad shape
he clearly drinks too much but they seem
to understand where it's all coming from
so how did she end up living beneath the
severed floor or living at all
considering people accept that she died
in this car accident if you try to put
it all together there are basically
three starting points first is that she
never died somehow this accident was
staged it didn't happen and she just
took herself out of mark's life second
is that she's a clone or a robot or
something that isn't exactly gemma but
is based on her the third is that the
accident is real but somehow lumen got a
hold of her body and is experimenting on
it the first one her being alive and
just choosing to live on the testing
floor at lumen doesn't seem likely to me
i guess i should say that i do expect
that lumen is up to some nefarious stuff
behind the scenes but people have to
volunteer for the severance program it's
not a secret the corporation doesn't
have to coerce them into this because
for some people their conditions are so
miserable that they think like what the
hell maybe it'll make things better if
you read the lexington letter they give
a pretty good example of how some people
would be enthusiastic about the chance
to earn a decent salary and overlook the
possible drawbacks of getting the chip
leaving everything you care about to
live there forever is a totally
different situation this would be like
committing suicide your audi would cease
to exist and you would have to put your
family through the pain of experiencing
your death this is not the kind of thing
that people would do for money there's a
different level of desperation that
would be involved plus we know there's
public backlash to severance just for
the work time hours it doesn't seem
possible that they would be able to get
away with offering full-time severance
and from there things get pretty
complicated as far as trying to put
together a story of how that would work
the second idea her being a clone or a
robot is more in line with common sci-fi
situations but i think for it to be
interesting there would have to be a lot
more going on obviously they are this
huge corporation that could make robots
it's possible what point is there to the
one we've been introduced to being
mark's ex-wife or if it were clones it's
sort of the same question why clone
gemma and then have marxini work around
her what would be the motivation behind
that this was one of the early theories
that came mostly from the way she
interacted in mdr and then the obvious
thing where she's dead so why is she
walking around could she be a robot i
don't think this is the way that they're
going but we'll see what happens lumen
getting her body after the accident
seems like the most popular theory at
the moment kira appears to be a company
town where they have a lot of pull and
have their hands in a lot of pies
there's this weird family cult at the
center of it all but they're a medical
technology conglomerate so it's not a
stretch to think that they would have
connections and possible control of the
local hospitals maybe they could make it
look like someone died and removed the
body or probably the most popular theory
is that when someone is brain dead or in
a coma they take that person to the
testing floor and lumen brings them back
in some fashion so far nothing about the
severance chips makes it seem like they
can do anything other than spatially
dictate access to a person's memories
you can only access the innies memories
at work when the chip is activated or as
we've seen with the overtime contingency
protocol on the testing floor there
might be something completely different
going on though and that might account
for the need for some bodies i think
these theories are the most probable i
do think there was an accident and from
what we've seen from lumen you can
imagine them conducting experiments on
living subjects if the opportunity
presented itself in the example of a
patient being brain dead and especially
if they had a do not resuscitate order
it's plausible that they could justify
this in some twisted way
so gemma being brain dead after the
accident seems like the easiest way to
get from a to b the fact that so many
people came up with this idea
independently shows that the setup is
there but i think there's one problem
with it if she was brain dead it's not
clear that mark's wife is in there at
all at this point the coma might be a
better route to keep the idea of them
coming back together alive but then
you're getting into even murkier waters
about how they're obtaining bodies for
their experiments as if reanimating
brain dead people isn't murky enough as
far as having severed mark interact with
her this would reinforce that their
memories are completely separate as
milcek said that the chips are working
but it does seem that there's more going
on than that harmony was pushing this
she essentially tempted them to remember
each other it was like she was trying to
make it happen i tend to think that this
is probably more about her i think she
may have her own agenda even though
she's a true believer in care and
somehow this knowledge that she has
about mark and gemma fits into her
overall plan i don't want to go too far
away from miss casey in this video
because there's a lot of speculation to
be done on what lumen is up to and how
that aligns with what harmony is
interested in personally but the
corporation is not just bringing people
back to pat out their workforce i think
that cobell probably wants to bring back
her mother based on her shrine
the charlotte cobell hospital bracelet
and the breathing tube but i'll get more
into that when i make a video about what
lumen's plans might be there's one bit
from a post finale interview that i want
to touch on variety asked the show's
creator dan erickson what he could say
about why mark and gemma are involved in
this situation to begin with the
interviewer made the point that it was
clear that lumen faked her death and
that ultimately worked out in a way that
prompted mark not knowing any of this to
join lumen but it's unclear why lumen
wants them eriksen said there's a
question of sort of who was targeted
first was mark targeted because of his
relationship to gemma or was it the
other way around and that's something
that we don't see this season but we
will see in subsequent seasons that's
the big question what's special about
mark and is it actually that there's
something special about him or is it
more about gemma and he was sort of
pulled in those are all left unanswered
this season but we will get into it so
we do have that to look forward to i
also just want to add that there's a
strong implication that lumen could be
involved in the car accident that led to
the death of the whistleblower from the
lexington letter book in that her innie
was able to communicate with her audi
who got worried about what might be
happening on the severed floor she tried
to go to the press who were sympathetic
to lumen one of the editors there had
the last name milchik so they never
printed the story and the author died
not long after that so that's something
to think about i think that's a good
place to leave things i think we'll
learn that gemma is alive but if lumen
has their way she'll never leave the
building it's not clear how much of the
woman mark loved is still inside but
considering this is his motivation for
getting severed in the first place i'd
like to find out a lot of season one
revolved around him trying to get
himself back together to become whole
again and we did hear hely ask dylan if
love transcends severance let me know in
the comments what you think is going on
and how you expect things to play out
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon